way we do
oh
pour autant qu'on sait comment le faire
on peut parier sur n'importe quoi dans
ce port de la couleur du gatorade au
super bowl aux normes de but que marc
concas feared au cours de sa carrière
895 jusqu'au chevalot nom loufoque qui
gagnera le droit d'être aimé de riches
américains avec des chapeaux encore plus
loufoque soupe and switch me demande
s'ils font ça avec la viande de cheval
mais alors que les ligues
nord-américaines et est récalcitrante à
l'idée de promouvoir les paris jusqu'à
récemment
elles ont clairement changé leur fusil
d'épaulé depuis que la cour suprême
américaine dit vous pouvez miser si vous
voulez personne peut vous empêcher par
comme down le jugement de meyzieu 5,49
pas justement meilleur résumé
conséquemment la lnh la haine billets la
mls le baseball majeur et la nfl ont
tous maintenant des partenaires
officiels pour le pari sportif le club
de foot montréal et les alouettes qui
existent encore sont désarmés commandité
par un site de paris sportifs le signal
que ça envoie ce si tu veux vraiment à
être impliqué émotionnellement dans la
victoire comme dans la défaite paris sur
nous paris / nous doit savoir c'est quoi
souffrir comme joey saputo et quand ils
vont miser sur nous tu vas juste avoir
envie de descendre dans le vestiaire
avec lui pour dire aux joueurs ta façon
de penser parce que toi aussi ça va être
ton arche au passage tu vas voir la même
agonie que cha johnson enseignements
ochocinco qui a perdu le salaire moyen
québécois en une soirée en misant sur le
mauvais combat tin oo youssef 6 261
le risque de commencer à parier sur le
sport c'est justement d'en avoir besoin
pour ressentir ces mêmes émotions
ensuite je à la dépendance
il risque cette virée comme adam sandler
pas le porteur d'eau le parieur
compulsif danko james ça va le parti
veut avoir un oscar comme adam sandler
de news corp croit la drogue passerelle
dans ce cas c'est qu'ils te fais glisser
doucement dans cet univers c'est les
ligues de rôtisserie plus connue
aujourd'hui sous le nom de ligue 2
fantaisie et le monde du sport l'a
parfaitement compris puisqu'il ya
maintenant quantité de ligue 2 fantasy
quotidienne qui s'assure de faire le
transfert d'un innocent en retour est
pour lui un peu plus clair obscur du
pari bon et l'ex-sportif joue maintenant
sur deux tableaux d'un côté les ligues
et cite les amateurs par tous les moyens
à dépenser davantage en misant sur les
match et de l'autre elle continue de
tenir la ligne dure face à ceux qui ont
succombé aux sirènes des paris pendant
leur carrière
le tabou demeure la chose que tu ne peux
pas faire c'est parier sur un match
auquel tu prends part et où est la
limite ci-dessus cision de l'équipe et
ce qu'on a avec des villes cache une
blessure comment pas empêché de paris
contre hearts ou ci-dessus parient sur
le fait qu'ils ont eu vite au super bowl
pourquoi pas être levé ça c'est mon
pitch pour nationaliser en hiver peu
importe le prochain grand scandale de
paris sportifs sera probablement
commandité et avant de condamner il
faudra peut-être demander mes cheveux de
sang et avant de condamner à mes cheveux
donc avant de condamner il faudra
peut-être se demander comment on en est
arrivé là
et si rendu leur vous vous posez la
question réécoutez la capsule il ya des
pistes de réponses
merci pour tout on prend pas vos paris
mais on peut prendre vos j'aime et vos
commentaires salut
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup de street cred